so much for that bull market right
exactly and that just what it raises the
point that was this all a technical Ed
Morris over at Citigroup had no doubt
right as that rally broke yesterday
saying that about twenty to twenty-five
percent of crude oil spike price since
last week was actually driven by
sentiment I'm not reality and let's take
a look at the two factors that drove oil
higher yesterday one you had the news
that perhaps OPEC was going to be
willing to talk about finding a better
price favorable greater price right so
perhaps talking to other non OPEC
members hey guys let's get together and
talk about price Citigroup pointed out
all the big OPEC officials are on
vacation so obviously there couldn't
have been real high-level discussions on
this and I raised the question yesterday
who would actually cut when you see Iran
is increasing its output as his Iraq
Saudi Arabia scaling back a little bit
but that's probably due to seasonal
demand factors instead the other factor
that really had an impact was the EIA
lowered the US production by about 70
excuse me eighty seven thousand barrels
a day and put June US production down by
about one hundred and four thousand
barrels a day okay is that a big number
well that's still 9.4 million barrels a
day so yes if you read it into the tea
leaves it does mean that US production
is rolling over faster than expected but
goldman sachs raised the question you
know there needs to be even lower prices
you got a lot of backlog wells ongoing
productivity games higher grading you're
getting more for less in the oil
community some more damage still needs
to be done to the oil price in order for
these sustained production cuts to be
felt alright so let's put this all into
context here and bring in some other
asset classes as well I want to bring in
lease Abramowitz to talk about oil
prices rise in correlation with European
bond yields Lisa you've been covering
fixed income for years now how often
have you heard about European bond
yields moving with oil well it comes and
goes and actually this is something
that's a little bit of a challenge right
now to both policymakers and bond
investors where you have a pretty direct
correlation with the moves and oil
prices and the moves in the safe haven
bonds the US Treasuries and the German
boons but you know we don't have a sense
exactly to Alex's point of exactly all
the technicals that are necessarily
behind each particular move you know if
the if if the iaea comes out and says
something and has a proclamation and it
changed it isn't that immediately affect
bond yields this could really complicate
the matter for investors who are looking
to bond yields to get clues on are we
headed toward inflation or we headed
toward deflation and it's hard for
policymakers who are looking at this and
saying you know should we raise right so
this is this basically an indication
that people are ratcheting back their
expectations for inflation or is this
just purely a technical blip I mean
Janet Yellen has come out and said you
know oil prices that the decline has is
a transitory trend which has been
transitory for a very long time
temporary not something that they want
to take into account when it comes to
inflation and what they do next what
about other policymakers have European
policy makers Mario Draghi for instance
or the UK Mark Carney brought up oil
prices and the move higher as reason to
to change their policy they have talked
about concern about the drop in oil
prices I think that Europe a people who
I talked to say Europe is much more
directly affected by the slowdown in
China more so than even the u.s. so you
know to the extent that the drop in oil
prices of late has been related at all
to what's going on in China and some of
the slow down there there actually is an
actual tangible reason that this slows
the European economy that goes beyond
just a technical bond yield correlation
issue and quite frankly Scarlett the
concern is that the oil price community
will see even lower prices going forward
Barclays had a no doubt talking about
the next glut we might see might be in
the product market and that global
refinery throughput is at a record high
right now almost 81 million barrels a
day in July there for refiners work
really hard make a lot of product
margins are awesome make too much
product margins not awesome they're not
going to work as hard they use less
crude oil prices go even lower to demand
that supply response hmm so it all comes
down to a very confusing a muddling read
for policymakers how our investors
positioning themselves when they look at
this rising correlation then well some
people are just it really depends on
their worldview it comes down to what's
your biggest fear is it deflation is it
inflation
they just you want to hold a lot of cash
because you don't know what the
direction is and people have to kind of
stick with that the people who I talk to
rather than look to some kind of
correlation because even the correlation
changes over time there are times when
it's been a negative correlation you ran
down there on the chart just even a few
months ago that was a negative
correlation exactly but it is telling
that they're moving in such lockstep
because it does indicate that either oil
or both the oil and the bond yields are
indicating that people are reducing
their expectations for growth okay
correlation is not causation though
right we don't know what's causing what
what's the leading indicator here is it
oil is it the yields the short market in
oil that's what I'm gonna argue look at
how many shorts are in the oil market
and then you'll know what's going to
happen because you have one headline
boom you're gonna have a really powerful
rally when there's so many shorts and
that's what I would say oh you know I
would say it's very hard to tell there
is some disparity right now if I look
for example the five-year five-year
forwards they're not showing the same
kind of expectations for such a slowdown
in growth that you would think from some
of the bond yields bond yields have been
distorted by some of the central bank
buying program so there's there are a
lot of technical issues that make it
hard for me to really use either of them
you look at reddit and it speaks to how
confusing it is out there that
everyone's looking at every kind of
indication for correlation for
dislocation to get some sense of what's
going to happen next and there's been a
breakdown